we're joined by governor steve sisilak
on 8 news now governor first of all
let me just say thank you for the time
we do appreciate it
it's an honor pleasure to be with you
and talk to your viewers
governor it has been one year since the
first case of covid in nevada
the flags were flown at half staff the
video tribute put together by your
office
in a year rife with challenges what was
the biggest one for you and your team
well i missed that question a lot you
know what was the biggest the hardest
uh we've come a long way in a year so
much has happened
in one year you can't even imagine when
i got elected governor the first year we
did our business we had a session and
we're getting into our uh proposals in
terms
of funding education better and
healthcare and then wham we got hit with
a pandemic that
nobody ever expected the magnitude of
this uh
the decision early on to close the
schools
and to shut down the strip was extremely
hard for me
i mean i consulted with all of my staff
all the scientists all the medical
examiners
and uh originally when we shut down the
schools if you remember it was only for
a couple weeks that we shut them down
and then it went on
but i remember the day that we meet i
finally made the decision to shut down
the strip las vegas boulevard i told
this story i walked out on my balcony at
the grand sawyer building
and looked it downtown you could see it
it was just turning the nighttime and
you could see all the lights
on the strip and you could see all the
lights downtown and to think about
shutting that down meant that those
lights were all going to go out
and those people were all going to be
out of work was really really hard to do
because i knew the impact it was going
to have the toll it was going to take on
human life
the toll it was going to take on
people's finances and the ability to
support their families
and we did it and i know it was the
right thing to do i'm glad we did it
when we did
uh but it was difficult it was really
difficult
it really when you look down the strip
in those days it was almost eerie and
think about each and every one of those
people as i know you do when you look
back at this year
what is something you are most proud of
and what is something if you could get a
do-over
uh a mulligan if you will something you
wish maybe a decision was made slightly
differently
as we kind of look in a retrospective
way yeah
the thing that and before i get to that
i want to say when what you said is true
when i drove down this trip i had my
detail my security take me on a
trip down the strip one time to go to
work more than once
and to see the eeriness of nobody on the
strip and nobody open
and you know it was difficult the thing
that i
am most proud of or i'm happiest about
is you saw the absolute best in people
through this pandemic and you saw the
worst in people through this pandemic
you had some folks that would not chose
not to comply with any of the directives
and didn't want to believe that believe
that coleman is a hoax
but at the same time you saw the best in
people you saw the nevada national guard
you saw them feeding people giving cove
a test
cleaning nursing homes uh giving covet
vaccines
delivering food delivering ppe they have
done absolutely everything we've asked
of them
all of the individuals that have donated
whether it's food whether it's money
whether it's their time
to help a neighbor that was in need if
they knew they had a senior citizen
living next door
they couldn't get out to buy if you
remember at the very beginning you
couldn't get toilet paper
wipes they don't they they went and got
it and brought it to their neighbors
that weren't so fortunate
that was uh really heartwarming to see
how much people
uh sacrificed and did for other people
uh the difficult parts the two parts
were
one uh when you deal with families of
those who have lost a loved one
and you know that that person couldn't
get in to say goodbye
you know when the person was dying and
they counted on a nurse
being with them to hold their hand to
face time with their family that's how
they got to say goodbye
that was difficult that's extremely
difficult that people had to go through
that and couldn't have a
a proper goodbye to a loved one couldn't
have a proper burial
for a loved one and people made an awful
lot of sacrifices to that extent
governor a lot of good news lately in
terms of cases plummeting especially in
the past six seven weeks
uh sporting events coming back if you
could clarify
with the fact that the governor's office
for nascar weekend and golden knights
games put capacity at 20
and it seemed to be reduced to 15 from
southern nevada health
district we heard from bill foley and
and chris powell and their frustration
with that wanting
the 20 that you talked about to be what
happens
can you explain what exactly happened
there sure i talked to bill
uh who i'm a big fan of both the golden
ice and the speedway has been a
tremendous thing for this community
uh we made a decision based on
our medical the medical advice i got our
science advice we got a business in
industry they looked at all the plans
all these
venues that they're going to put to
people in and i felt very very
comfortable going with 20
occupancy they could still be socially
distanced
uh they could still be safe i thought
for everybody involved
we made that uh part of a directive i
made that statement
and then the local jurisdictions whether
it's the
county or the city or the health
district said no we don't want to
give them 20 we only want to give them
15
i know there was a lot of frustration
with both chris and bill
as it related to that i understand their
frustration i know that they've had
people that have been waiting a year
to get into a race or to get into a
hockey game
and i understand that and uh like i say
i wanted 20
but the locals said that was they wanted
melt less so they ended up with less
governor more than half of a recent poll
supported your handling of the cobit
pandemic
over half were you uh as you look at the
43
that maybe did not how do you speak to
those that you're still trying to bring
on board
and what does it mean to you that over
have to approve of the job you've done
well i appreciate the fact that over
half approve of the job that we've done
it's not me it's
i've got to assemble the great team i
mean whether it's my staff here in
carson city with me or
what's the doctors and the medical
professionals or colvin task force
uh our profit advisory committee that
rolls out all this stuff
we're taking the best information we can
and moving forward
for the people that uh don't support
what i'm doing or how we're doing it
i understand that i still represent you
i still want to do the best i possibly
can
but some people just i understand that
they
most people think you should wear a mask
but they don't want to be told to wear a
mask
and i get that but i'm telling you it
works it makes a big big difference i
wish people would look at it
uh from the point of view if you don't
wear the mask for yourself as much as
you wear it for the people that you love
and the people you care about the people
you live with the people you work with
uh people you live near you know your
family members
and i would encourage everybody to
please do your part now is not the time
to let up and take your foot off the gas
so to speak
uh now is the time to double down and
continue as we get more and more people
vaccinated every day
we get thousands of more people of
accident
thousands of shots in people's arms so
every day it's getting a little bit
better
yeah then you just need people we need
to hold down for a couple more
uh months in order to get get where we
can get to that immunity of 80 to 90
then we'll be in great shape yeah the
news continues to get brighter well put
and you aptly pointed out the
individuals the people that have lost
their jobs we've talked about
the 295 000 cases in nevada we talk
about the over 5 000 that have died
the individuals that have lost their
jobs they're struggling with a
way of life that is due to them a lot of
issues with dieter
you've talked a lot about this how do
you explain what went
wrong at times with dieter and are we
turning the corner
yeah and that's a great question i
appreciate the chance to address that
dieter is in a difficult situation we
had a system that was set up
that when we originally shut everything
down and we're in the thrones of the
pandemic
our claims to dieter were 25 times what
they normally were
instead of getting 12 000 in a week we
had 300
000 claims in a week i mean no system
is set up to handle that kind of a
volume
the past legislatures have not invested
into a new
computer system technology for dieter
which is unfortunate i wish they would
have
they have not staffed it up the way they
should have at the same time
you can't staff it up for 300 000 claims
a week when you're only getting twelve
thousand clams a week or everybody be
sitting around and we'd be paying them
to do nothing
so that wouldn't work that was a problem
the system was not set up to handle this
and hopefully we will learn as we move
forward so we'll get it better
also the biggest problem i've talked to
our director today
we have five hundred thousand claims for
uh d for
ui or a pua
uh and they are estimating 95
of us 95 are fraudulent
five percent of them are legitimate so
what happens
not only are you hurting the state and
the businesses
because these small businesses that
exist are going to have to the money
that we spent they've got to put back
into the dieter uh
trust fund you know to get more money in
there for so we can continue the program
going
and they've clogged up the system so
much
uh with these fake claims and phony
claims
that it's really impacted legitimate
claimants so
i'm talking to my staff i think it's
important we do something about this and
this isn't 475 000
different people that put in claims this
is a group of syndicator
whatever you want to call it the that
are putting in
tens of thousands of claims and getting
all these cards and getting the benefits
and i think we need to take a bolder
step in terms of
investigating and prosecuting the
perpetrators of that because
they continue to put in fraudulent
claims they're not
questionable where you don't know if you
should get it you shouldn't get it
these are people putting claims that
have no rights to it they're putting in
multiple claims under different names
stealing identities it's just a really
sad situation
95 percent fraudulent question about
vaccinations
uh we are uh getting a lot of shots in
arms in nevada we did find out that
nevada's vaccine allocation rate was
using 24 to
2014 to 2018 census estimates which was
impacting the numbers
are you happy with the vaccination
process as of now and what do you want
to see different to improve it
well i'm happy but i can always be
happier we have a weekly call the
governor's association does with the
president's task force on vaccines every
week i look forward to the call because
every week they've upped our allocation
you know we're getting more and more and
more
it's unfortunate that they're using old
population estimates which
which kind of goddesses is it's hurting
the states that are getting more people
moving and it's helping the states that
people are moving out of
so that's a problem for that uh what i
want to see happen
and we're going to continue to expand
our sites
that are going to be made available to
go get vaccines uh i want to see more
and more of our elderly population
get the vaccine my mom's 94. she got
both of hers so i'm thrilled with that
she can feel safer but we need to get
our senior citizens vaccinated
and we need to do more in our minority
communities and we're going to we're
going to get into those communities our
are black and brown communities where
there's a little more hesitancy
to get the vaccine but i want to open
these up and give out every single dose
that we could possibly get coming our
way
and uh i think we're going to continue
to do that right now you've got
this many vaccines and this many people
want in the vaccine
but it's slowly starting to change when
we're going to have this many vaccines
and to wait out here
people that are going to be willing to
get them so we need to continue to
educate people
to encourage them to go and get the
vaccine and the first chance you'd get
to get an appointment get a vaccine i
don't care which one it is
if it's a needle with a vaccine they're
putting in your arm go get it we're all
going to be better off as a result
governor we appreciate your time glad to
hear your mom
94 years old got the vaccines is doing
well
and thank you so much for making time
for us here on eight news now we do
appreciate it